There's a lot going on in the new trailer
for Spider-Man: Far From Home, including one
big reveal about the state of the MCU in the
wake of Avengers: Endgame.
But with an illusionist like Mysterio in the
mix, all might not be as it appears.
Now that we've seen the new trailer, here
are some small details you may have missed.
And by the way, big spoilers for Endgame ahead,
you've been warned.
For a brief moment in the trailer, we see
Peter Parker rocking a very familiar looking
pair of sunglasses.
That's right: those are Tony Stark's signature
shades.
While it's not very clear what he's doing
with them, he seems to have a pretty shocked
expression on his face after looking through
them.
That may have something to do with the fact
that those sunglasses are a bit more than
a gift from a fallen friend: they're probably
filled with Stark's signature nano-tech.
In Avengers: Infinity War, we see Stark put
those glasses on shortly after Cull Obsidian
and Ebony Maw appear on Earth.
When he does, he starts talking to his AI
assistant, Friday, which seems to indicate
that they provide a direct link to Stark technology
even without wearing an Iron Man suit.
Shortly afterward, when Stark activates his
nano-tech to turn into Iron Man, he takes
off his glasses, and they seem to actually
disappear in his hand.
So are the glasses an advanced piece of Stark
nano-technology that helps Peter in his fight
in Far From Home?
Or are they simply a bold fashion statement
that will earn him lots of mockery from his
friends?
Only time will tell.
"Sup, dickwad."
Marvel has a history of altering trailer footage
to feed the hype machine, like including Hulk
at the Battle of Wakanda in the Infinity War
spot, or leaving a ton of it on the cutting
room floor, like Black Widow getting her aggression
out at the firing range in those Endgame trailers.
The latest Spider-Man: Far From Home trailer
is no exception, with a sneaky Spider Suit
switcheroo happening between the "Teaser Trailer"
and the "Official Trailer."
In the Teaser Trailer, Peter is seen sporting
his Homecoming-era suit while making his appearance
with Aunt May at the Salvation Army's "Homeless
Support" event in NYC.
Your Friendly Neighborhood Spider-Man is still
outfitted in the iconic red-and-blue backstage,
minus the mask, when he's caught in the middle
of May and Happy's flirt session.
But in the latest Official Trailer, Peter
is wearing his Iron Spider suit at the event,
meaning the Teaser Trailer clips were either
shot twice or there's some seamless CGI in
play.
We know it's the same location because of
the recessed lights above the kitchen prep
area in the background.
So what gives?
Well, the Iron Spider suit has more significance
for Peter now that the suit's designer, once-reluctant
father figure Tony Stark, has passed on.
It's just speculation, but Marvel also probably
didn't want to blatantly spoil Peter's fate
in Endgame by showing him alive and well wearing
the same suit he disintegrated in at the end
of Infinity War.
Regardless, this Loki-level trickery is yet
another example of Marvel going to great lengths
to hide the details of its MCU blockbusters
in advance of opening day.
If the Spider-Man origin you remember is the
one from the first, Sam Raimi-directed Spider-Man
movie, you don't remember Crusher Hogan.
You remember Macho Man Randy Savage's Bonesaw
McGraw, who likely got that name because Savage
would never have played a character named
"Hogan."
Too much bad blood between him and the Hulkster.
But the wrestler Peter Parker originally took
on in the comics when he was looking for fame
was indeed named Crusher Hogan, and if you
look closely behind Happy Hogan, no relation,
you can see a poster advertising Crusher's
original offer: $100 to anyone who can stay
in the ring with him for three minutes.
There's also a little bell there, so maybe
this is the building where he issued the challenge.
We never saw the full origin of Tom Holland's
Spider-Man, but it's entirely possible to
believe he took on and beat Crusher prior
to the life-changing night his Uncle Ben died.
In July 2018, Deadline reported that Turkish
actor Numan Acar had taken on the role of
"Dmitri" in Spider-Man: Far From Home.
The report further theorized that he may be
playing Dmitri Smerdyakov, a half-brother
of Kraven the Hunter known better to Spider-Man
fans as Chameleon.
He's one of Spider-Man's oldest rogues, appearing
all the way back in Amazing Spider-Man #1.
Is he in the trailer?
It's hard to say, but there are lots of places
he could be, given that Chameleon's whole
deal is that he can look like anyone, just
like Mystique in the X-Men movies.
One of the criminals Spider-Man apprehends
in the fancy ballroom early on in the trailer
is wearing what look like leopard-print pajamas.
This may be an early Dmitri appearance, wearing
something similar to what his fur-loving relative
would sport.
Or he could be throughout the rest of the
trailer, looking like just about anyone.
We have to assume Mysterio is up to no good.
Could the Nick Fury or Maria Hill Spider-Man
meets in Italy be Chameleon in disguise, working
on Mysterio's behalf in some huge ruse?
They definitely have a lot of reasons in their
back pocket as to why only Spider-Man can
do this job.
Or heck, he may be MJ.
"I mean it's kind of obvious."
While the impacts of Peter and countless others
missing out on five years of life are still
up in the air, one thing in the second Far
From Home trailer is pretty clear: this new,
revived world has nothing but love for Iron
Man.
The trailer starts with Peter looking at a
giant mural of the fallen hero on the side
of a building in New York City, but that's
far from the only tribute that Tony gets.
In addition to a memorial that appears to
be somewhere in Europe, viewers can also see
many drawings of Iron Man in the background
of an art class at Peter's school, showing
that the world post-Endgame recognizes that
it owes everything, or, well, half of everything,
to the one, the only, invincible Iron Man.
Tony was a huge part of Peter's origin story
in the MCU, and even in death, he still looms
large over Peter's day-to-day world, whether
he's out doing hero things or just trying
to finish high school after five weird years
away.
Towards the end of the trailer, Peter can
be seen with a Spider-Man-styled hologram
over his wrist.
He reacts to the device with some surprise,
looking offscreen to catch somebody's eye.
The way the trailer is edited, it appears
he's looking at Happy Hogan.
It isn't clear exactly where they are, but
they seem to be surrounded by some relatively
high-tech decor, maybe on board Happy's sick-looking
jet.
It seems possible that Tony's left at least
one more surprise behind for Peter, with the
wrist tech seeming to hearken back to a similar,
physical bracelet Peter showed off during
the end credits stinger of Captain America:
Civil War.
Alternatively, this could be some sort of
device from the mysterious Quentin Beck, who's
been known in the comics to use technology
and illusions to present the appearance of
superpowers.
The only thing we can tell from Pete's expression
is he's surprised.
Good surprised?
Bad surprised?
We'll find out soon.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.